sacamos las cuentas del día hoy en la
economía con consultado jorge muy buen
día bienvenido hablemos de los ministros
de energía de la unión europea que
continúan el debate sobre la respuesta
al alza de los precios no así es están
en una reunión extraordinaria que fue
convocada precisamente como reacción a
esta alza de los precios que se vive en
todos los países de la unión europea el
aumento del precio de la energía raúl
tiene sus raíces en la demanda del gas
en ese continente básicamente existe una
sobredemanda porque son países que
dependen de la importación de gas
principalmente de rusia y las reservas
no fueron suficientes españa italia
grecia y francia proponen fijar los
precios en el mercado mayorista del gas
así como un plan de compra conjunta de
gas por parte de los países de la unión
europea pero alemania países bajos y
otros emitieron una declaración antes de
la reunión rechazando la propuesta y
apuestan a medidas más locales para
enfrentar este aumento de los precios en
la comisión europea presentó también una
serie de medidas para mitigar el aumento
a corto plazo escuchamos un poco lo que
dijeron los ministros al entrar a esta
reunión hoy
por mí eres ver en por ti para mí es muy
importante escuchar las opiniones de
todos los ministros porque como saben
las circunstancias difieren en toda
europa y se necesita una visión completa
para tomar decisiones correctas espero
escuchar mensajes claros de los
ministros cuáles son sus expectativas
estregar light you go to hear clear
message está ministrers cambiamos ahora
información o jorge venimos al sur del
continente americano porque el
presidente socialista de perú pedro
castillo quiere nacionalizar la
industria del gas natural precisamente
hablando también del gasto en algunas
declaraciones instó al congreso
inclusive a comenzar a redactar esta ley
para nacionalizar
el sector del gas el presidente peruano
ha dicho durante su campaña que promovía
temas como la nacionalización de ciertas
industrias como el gas y la minería pero
desde que asumió el cargo en julio había
dicho que mantendría las industrias en
manos privadas e incentivaría la
inversión privada la nacionalización
debe ser aprobada por el congreso de
perú que en su mayoría son de derecha
pero que es el segundo productor mundial
de cobre tiene una importación una
importante operación
dirigida por el consorcio camisea
liderado por la argentina pluspetrol con
participaciones menores de la surcoreana
sk group
junhold y repsol es a la calificadora
moody's había advertido que perú
enfrenta un riesgo ilimitado de que la
nueva administración aumenta el control
estatal de las reservas de petróleo y
gas la producción de gas de camisea
abastece a casi el 86 por ciento de la
demanda de gas licuado en perú jorge en
brasil el gobierno del presidente air
bolsonaro creó un comité para el
desarrollo de una economía verde
imagínese así que bueno este comité se
va a encargar precisamente de promover
una agricultura sostenible y el cuidado
del medio ambiente aunque hay muchas
críticas en torno al manejo de los
recursos naturales el comité
interministerial sobre cambio climático
de crecimiento verde se encargará de
planificar y ejecutar políticas públicas
de preservación combinadas con proyectos
de desarrollo económico en regiones muy
sensibles como la amazonía brasil afirma
que sus esfuerzos para reducir la
deforestación desde 2006 valen entre
30.000 y 40.000 millones de dólares y
que otros países del mundo deberían
aportar económicamente en la el gobierno
ha sido crítico ha sido muy criticado
por la construcción de esta zona de
conservación lo que respondieron que no
pueden renunciar a la construcción de
carreteras y a la minería en la mayor
selva tropical del mundo la inversión de
minería en brasil raúl va a superar los
41 mil millones de dólares para 2025 y
encendieron ya las alarmas de varios
organismos de conservación ambiental
escuchamos que decía el ministro de
economía de brasil ayer
como país comemos cómo es posible que el
país que menos contamina sea el país más
agredido internacionalmente y el país
que tiene la mayor reserva de
preservación de recursos naturales sea
también el país más agredido
internacionalmente así que evidentemente
hay intereses políticos comerciales y
proteccionistas detrás de esta crítica
abras atrás tasas critiques obras jorge
hurtado indicadores económicos bueno
arrancamos en asia las acciones de hong
kong terminaron a la baja el martes
arrastradas por las empresas
tecnológicas e inmobiliarias en europa
las acciones llegaron a máximos de siete
semanas debido al optimismo general
sobre la temporada de beneficios del
tercer trimestre jorge se ha montado
alguna vez en un tesla todavía no yo
tampoco qué tristeza bueno al propósito
de eso vamos con la cifra del día hertz
encargo cien mil teclas como parte de un
ambicioso plan para electrificar su
flota una primera tanda estaría
disponible para alquiler en eeuu y
europa a inicios de noviembre y bueno
tras el anuncio de compra el precio de
las acciones de tecla alcanzó hasta 998
puntos 74 dólares a primera hora del día
aumentando su capitalización bursátil
un billón de dólares antes de que el
precio volviera a caer ahora íbamos
hasta brasil porque precisamente de ahí
sale nuestro reportaje del día por
supuesto veámoslo
[Música]